so mariah
um
um
we're gonna have to do this
right now
uh
it was nice it was a little pressure
game
fell on location
yeah i was in i wasn't short
honestly
oh yeah
uh
oh
yep
um
here
okay
um
so
okay
check one two testing testing check
check check
test one two everybody good all right
okay
oh um
what's up
um
foreign
oh
wait a minute
those
gives you more um yeah
oh
um
uh
hello everyone um i'm kaylee mcinerney
here today in my personal capacity
as an advisor to the campaign this
election
is not over far from it we have only
begun the process of obtaining an
accurate
honest vote count we are fighting for
the rights
of all americans who want to have faith
and confidence
not only in this election but in the
many elections to come
there is only one party in america
that opposes voter id one
party in america that opposes verifying
signatures
citizenship residency eligibility
there is only one party in america
trying to keep observers out of the
count room
and that party my friends is the
democrat party
you don't take these positions because
you want an honest election
you don't oppose an audit of the vote
because you want an accurate count
you don't oppose our efforts at sunlight
and transparency because you have
nothing
to hide you take these positions because
you are welcoming fraud
and you are welcoming illegal voting our
position is clear
we want to protect the franchise of the
american people
we want an honest accurate lawful count
we want maximum sunlight we want maximum
transparency we want every legal vote to
be counted
and we want every illegal vote to be
discarded
unlike our opponents we have nothing to
hide
the integrity of our election matters
the constitution
of the united states matters what we
have seen across the country
is democrat officials systematically
trying to do an end run
around the constitution to tip the
scales of the election
in their favor as justice gorsuch wrote
in dnc
versus wisconsin state legislature our
oath to uphold the constitution is
tested by hard times
not easy ones last-minute changes to
long-standing election rules risk other
problems too
inviting confusion and chaos and eroding
public confidence and electoral outcomes
pennsylvania is a case study in just
this
allow me to just broadly review three
points that have happened in
pennsylvania number one
in philadelphia poll watchers who are
legally legally permitted
to be there and observe the vote count
were blocked
from observing the count our poll
watchers were put behind
barricades in a massive room they were
many feet from the counting process and
in fact when you look at all of the
tables many
hundreds of feet in fact from the tables
in the very back
they were completely in the dark
completely unable to oversee
the vote count as was their legal right
an observer on the scene described it
this way
imagine being on a football field you're
on the 10-yard line and expected to make
a call
in the end zone on the other side of the
field it is unacceptable
an intermediary court ruled on the side
of the campaign on the side of
transparency in allowing
the poll watchers to observe the count
but what did the democrat pennsylvania
supreme court do
they issued an administrative stay
effectively pushing back our poll
watchers and denying them the access
they deserve
to sit and watch the count ask yourself
this
what are pennsylvania democrats hiding
why can't poll watchers simply observe
the count second article 1 section 4 of
the united states constitution clearly
states this the time
place and manner of holding elections
for senators and representatives
shall be prescribed in each state by the
legislature thereof that's right
the state legislature is
constitutionally the one
making the decision but the supreme
court of the commonwealth of
pennsylvania kathy bookvar and the
democrat tilted
pennsylvania supreme court have
continually disregarded the constitution
making decisions
clearly in the domain of the
pennsylvania legislature
in fact maybe there's a reason the
secretary of state
bookvar keeps substituting her will for
that of the legislature
in a completely unconstitutional fashion
perhaps it's because she has motive in
fact
she has shown her partisan hatreds
tweeting this
using the title quote president before
the word quote trump
really just means the office of the
presidency we see where her motives
stand
and finally a mere survey of the facts
shows that voters in blue counties like
philadelphia county
were given certain privileges that
voters in red counties were not afforded
the constitution's equal protection
clause requires uniform standards but
democrat election officials
created disparities depending on where
citizens lived
and where they voted in the state some
counties set up satellite offices for
backdoor early voting
whereas other counties did not some
counties
allowed pre-canvassing where other
counties did not
voters in some counties were allowed to
cure their ballots
whereas voters in other counties were
not
what pennsylvania has done is provide a
case study
into how to tip the scales of an
election to functionally favor the
democrat party
this has gone on nationwide and i'll
leave you with this in dnc versus
wisconsin state legislature in another
attempt
to count late ballots that arrived after
the election
justice gorsuch wrote nothing in our
founding document
contemplates the kind of judicial
intervention that took place here
nor is there precedent for it in 230
years
of the court's decisions he went on to
say
no one doubts that conducting a national
election
amid a pandemic poses serious challenges
but none of that means
individual judges may improvise with
their own election
rules in place of those the people's
representatives have adopted
they have taken a global pandemic and
turned it into a nationwide electoral
epidemic they have taken uh based on
what they call a natural
disaster they have used that and turned
this into a national disaster
and with that i'll turn it over to matt
morgan general counsel for the campaign
thank you kaylee
as kaylee stated the election is not
over tabulation and canvassing continues
across the united states and today in
the united states district court for the
middle district of pennsylvania
the donald j trump for president and two
representative voters filed suit against
the secretary of state and select
counties
alleging two things number one a
violation of equal access based on a
lack of meaningful observation
and transparency particularly in
democrat-controlled counties
and secondly a violation of equal
protection based on disparate treatment
between republican voters and democrat
voters
but what does this mean in layman's
terms what does this mean for all of you
what this means is if you are a democrat
in philadelphia you are allowed to
work outside the bounds of the
restrictions on
fixing defective ballots sometimes
referred to as curing
but if you're in republican counties in
the state of pennsylvania
you're not allowed to do that because
they're strictly following the text of
the statute
in pennsylvania secondly if you were a
republican
in the city of philadelphia for example
you are not allowed meaningful access to
the observation of the vote tabulation
process
if you are a democrat and a republican
leaning county in the state of
pennsylvania
you were allowed that access to
meaningfully view
the ballots as they're being counted
there are
in philadelphia and allegheny counties
there were over 682 000 ballots that
were tabulated
outside the view of our observers who
are entitled by law
to review those ballots and we believe
that a meaningful review of those
ballots
could discern that there were ballots
that were
illegally counted our relief that we're
seeking at this point
is to join the secretary of state from
hurring to certify the results before
they were
completely tabulated or canvassed so
that we can obtain that meaningful
review
and discern within those 682 000 ballots
at least and there may be more
throughout the state
whether or not there is disparate
treatment for republican voters and
democrat voters in the states
and whether democrat voters are
disproportionately allowed to cure
or fix their ballots in some locations
in the state and not others
and for example even at a minute level
here today
we are very close we are very close to
the automatic recount statute in
pennsylvania
and this lawsuit itself could could
change that or swing that
small discrepancy so this is the relief
we're seeking at this time
but i would also urge the press and
those out there that this is
step one of a process we are within our
rights to look into these irregularities
we were in our rights to observe the
votes as they are being tabulated
we will observe those and we believe
that this lawsuit takes us one step
closer
to closing the gap in the vote
differential in pennsylvania
and at this time i'll turn over to the
republican chairwoman
this weekend thank you all for coming
i'm going to start with uh some of the
irregularities we've seen in the state
of michigan specifically
and and then i'll go a little bit
broader but
michigan is my home state and then the
county uh wayne county republican
poll watchers were denied their legal
right to monitor the election
and purposely kept in the dark both
literally and figuratively pull walker
poll watchers or pull election workers
blocked windows and padlock doors
obviously
that's that's not going to instill
confidence um there are thousands of
reports of poll watchers being
intimidated and unable to do their job
and as of 4 p.m this afternoon 131
affidavits have been completed just in
michigan
with over 2 800 incident reports that
have been submitted
to us since election day two new
lawsuits were filed today by people who
were working who were working
in detroit and a whistleblower who has
gotten their information we have gotten
their information to the eastern
district court of michigan
as you guys can understand with 2800
incident reports
this is a lot to track down it means
we're interviewing these people we're
getting their statements and we're
turning them into affidavits
but that takes a lot of time and effort
and as
matt has mentioned there's a canvas
process and a certification for a reason
but i will just tell you the distress
that i'm hearing in my state from people
who were at tcf
and the way they were treated is deeply
alarming i hope you
go and look at this i hope you look at
these affidavits and i hope you hear
from the people that were there
who feel like they were denied
transparency and saw wrongdoing
in detroit we should all be alarmed by
this no matter where you are on the
political spectrum
in addition to that we've heard hundreds
of instances of election workers who
were verbally accosted
are pulled they verbally accosted our
poll watchers and refusals to let them
challenge questionable ballots election
workers were wearing biden t-shirts
and applauding when our poll watchers
were kicked out
imagine volunteering and going and
spending your night because you care so
much about the integrity of the election
and then to be kicked out and to be
cheered as you are leaving
this does not instill confidence in our
democracy and these are good people i
know most of these people
of the few ballots that democrat
election workers did allow us to
challenge
our observers say those ballots were
then moved back into the regular pile
after our poll watchers were intimidated
and pushed from the process
there is a canvas for a reason there is
a certification process for a reason
and unlike election day we need these
processes
to be transparent already in detroit we
are hearing
incidents and we will have affidavits to
this effect of people not being able to
meaningfully candace and
canvas and discrepancies that we're
seeing in detroit specifically
so just after a week after the polls
closed democrats and the media want to
ignore these clear
irregularities and rush to call states
as one and end the certification and
canvas process
we're hearing we need to unite we need
to come together well for the thousands
of people who spent time and hours
going out to be part of this process who
feel disenfranchised who don't feel like
there was transparency
we can't do that unless we we search out
all these irregularities even
one instance even one instance of voter
fraud should be too many for all of us
we intend to ensure that every lawful
voter has their vote
counted in accordance with the law that
observers are granted the access they
are due
under state law and that any
irregularities that have occurred
whether by malicious
intent or incompetence are investigated
to the fullest extent
allowed under the law we will not give
up on this process until
every last issue has been uncovered the
rnc has deployed legal teams in multiple
states to investigate clear
irregularities with voting
counting and tabulation and we will work
with state and local authorities to
ensure that a legal count is conducted
in accordance to each state's laws
and that every vote is counted if the
shoe were on the other foot
if it were this close the other way if
president trump was in the lead in all
these states
and the media would be screaming this
isn't over the race isn't over we need
more time to account and make sure it's
right but because it's biden and very
slightly
the media demands the race is over and
there's nothing to see here
the american people need to have
confidence
in their elections there are over a
hundred and fifty americans
who voted in this election and they
deserve to know that their votes were
counted accurately
right now and i can say this as i'm
hearing calls and hearing from people
across the country
they do not have confidence that that
happened so i am asking the media
interview these people talk to these
people do not just dismiss
these allegations out of hand these
irregularities go research it
because this is a problem when people
are not being able to transparently
watch
action counting which they are legally
allowed to do it creates division in our
country
republican and democrats should be
allowed to observe this problem
not allowed to we will continue to fight
president trump will continue to fight
for us and we'll continue to fight for
him
please go to visit.gop please visit
gop.com to donate and if you see signs
of voter irregularity go to 888-503-3526
thank you
i'll take a few questions yep haley
sounds like did you know that brushwood
votes were actually cast or are you
simply saying
we don't know look uh what we are asking
for here is patience ron i just
mentioned to you the more than i believe
it was 130 affidavits in michigan alone
we're aware of all the reports of
thousands of votes in nevada that were
cast by those who are not eligible we're
hearing
these reports we're seeing them come in
we are vetting them
we are getting affidavits so right now
we would point you to all of that that
information is publicly available but
what we're asking for right
now is patience as we explore these
equal protection claims among others
let me can i have that let me just add a
couple things in this recent lawsuit one
we do have a whistleblower which i
discussed
earlier this week who was in detroit as
an election worker
not as a republican poll watcher who
under affidavit
says that they were told to back date
ballots that their supervisor came
and they were there on november 4th
ballots that came in with no date they
were told
by the supervisor backdate the ballots
to november 2nd
or november 3rd so they will count so
that has been submitted
to the eastern uh to the u.s attorney in
the eastern district of michigan
that is via affidavit if you look at the
recent lawsuit and mike reed can get you
the
information on this lawsuit let me just
share an election employee with the city
of detroit working at a polling location
for three weeks prior to the election
this city of detroit employee directly
observed on a daily basis
other city of detroit election workers
and employees coaching voters to vote
for joe biden
and the democrat party this employee
witnessed these workers and employees
encouraging voters to do straight
democrat ballot and witness these
election workers and employees going
over to the voting booths
with voters in order to watch them vote
and coach them who to vote for
during the last two weeks while this
same employee was working at the polling
location
she was specifically instructed by her
supervisors never to ask for a driver's
license or any photo id when a person
was trying to vote
and as absentee ballots that existed
were
all absentee ballots that existed were
required to be input into the qvf system
by 9 pm on november 3rd
2020. this was required to be done in
order to have a
final list of absentee voters who
returned their ballots prior to 8 pm on
november 3rd
2020. in order to have enough time to
process the absentee ballots all polling
locations were instructed to collect the
absentee ballots
from the dropbox once every hour
november 3rd on november 4th
2020 a city of detroit election worker
was instructed to improperly predate
the absentee ballots received date and
were that were not in the qvf
she was told to alter the information in
the qvf to falsely show that the
absentee ballots have been received in
time to be valid
the election employee also observed a
large number of people who came into the
satellite location
to vote in person but they had already
applied for an absentee ballot
these people were allowed to vote in
person and were not required to return
the mailed absentee ballot or sign an
affidavit
that the voter lost the mail ballot
listen here's the thing why aren't you
worried about these irregularities
but no this is a separate question but
it's a separate question which is
if you are finding these irregularities
if you have an election worker being
told to back
date ballots that's a problem we're
going to pursue all of this
is it going to be enough no it's going
to take time is it going to be enough we
don't know
is it going to take time yes it's going
to take time but what we are seeing is
deeply alarming
along with the software where situation
we had in antrim county which we need to
get to the bottom of as well
now we have a whistleblower and now we
have a 30 131 affidavits
talking about irregularities and
problems that were happening in detroit
that's just michigan
you can look at this lawsuit mike can
you get them the lawsuit we'll get that
out to you
i don't know if that person's name it
may be a whistleblower so they may be
provided protections
that you can show us today
well i just i think i just went through
that with you with somebody
back dating ballots that's called
illegal if you are changing the date on
a ballot
an election worker a whistleblower well
how would i have we have to subpoena
that and we'll have to get that
information but that's going to be an
investigation process
but somebody was told you need to back
date ballots to make them legal ballots
that were illegal under the law
or conspiracy against that how was there
a conspiracy against
red counties and republican voters but
the
listen how is it a conspiracy when a
whistleblower from the city of detroit
is saying
i was told by my supervisors to lie and
back date ballots
this is somebody protected under the law
there's no conspiracy there
i i can answer at least regarding the
lawsuit today
in pennsylvania well the question is
about the republican party
no no but i'm saying you're saying
you're talking about how the disparate
treatment
so for example in the city of
philadelphia
if you do not provide an inner secrecy
envelope
ins with your ballot as you return it
that is not supposed to count but what
we know is happening in philadelphia is
somehow the city of philadelphia
knew knew which ballots had in our
secrecy envelopes and did not
and were telling voters ahead of time
hey you may not have included your
secrecy envelope
you need to get in here and vote a
provisional ballot and
get that fixed but that was only
happening in philadelphia
but not in that was not happening in the
rest of the state
because the state law discourages that
so as democrats were disproportionately
voting by mail
they were disproportionately picking up
those added votes in the city of
philadelphia
let me say one final thing there were
682
479 ballots counted in philadelphia
in allegheny county that there were no
poll watchers allowed to watch
it's the job of the media to ask the
question
why because all we are asking for is
truth
transparency and sunlight here that is
all we are asking for and sadly we are
asking the questions
many of you should
the president